I have a hard time with self-love like
yourself I'm ambitious and competitive
and I know how to compartmentalize my
emotions and Channel all of those
avoidant Tendencies into workaholism and
perfectionism and you know collecting
accolades and you know receiving
external validation and kind of chasing
that stuff right and so I think there's
an epidemic of people out there who we
have those pieces that drive us in a
certain way out of an interest of
protecting us that is why so much of
this kind of operates in a you know
shadowy Nether world because although
the body is indeed keeping score it
takes a long time for that sort of
scoreboard to show up and and for these
nascent compartmentalized emotions to to
Really you know show up let alone you
know turn into a volcano